it's time for our scene an unseen
segment where we unravel some of the big
cultural stories of the day tonight we
have meet two comebacks Trump musical
and a cardinal dismissing the sex abuse
scandal in the Catholic Church I'm
joined by Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor New York Times bestselling
author of the fantastic will Wilder
series Raymond the me to movement
claimed a lot of careers but now it
seems like comedian louis c.k is he was
out he's a big Trump basher by the way
and now he's in well we have FX HBO
Netflix they all canned him you remember
he exposed himself to women sexual
inappropriate actions he left he
apologized the Lord yeah now he's
staging a comeback and in New York the
other day he did a 15-minute set at a
little comedy club it's on the east side
and people are complaining particularly
his victim saying it's too early you
shouldn't have come back now this is a
little taste of his comedy I'm the guy
that women see in the gun and they're
still going uh and now Matt Lauer you up
today's show Fame he talked to some fans
at a restaurant it was reported in page
six this week he said I'm gonna be back
on TV soon now Matt Lauer had a list as
long as my arm of accusations against
him
the question is how long do you have to
stay in me to purgatory and my sense is
you have to have a public contrition you
need to be called out and shamed
publicly I think but then it's up to the
audience I mean these guys can put their
toes in the water and see if the
audience will accept them my guess is
they won't this scandal is bigger but
the memoir was like a lot of the blue
hairs were going up to him we were great
with Willard right they're kind of
they're like the glory days like we like
the Schmucker says Brian I got to tell
you about a new off-broadway musical
that was unveiled the other day by a
former is very brief White House
official he introduced the cast of a new
Trump musical at a New York press
conference I wish I were making this up
here's Anthony scaramouche II just this
great fun you know I mean I'm a my stock
answer is I always wanted a
second White House press conference and
I couldn't get one okay exactly last on
11 days so he introduced this cast who
are playing members of the Trump family
now I'll set this up very quickly this
is kind of like an Osmond special the
Trump family is gathering but Danny
Trump doesn't show up so Ivanka has to
assume the role as hostess and what does
a family do when Dad is detained
[Applause]
[Music]
scaramouche II who's been very nasty by
the way to my very nest even though he
sat where you said a couple times not
only time soon
but is he have some creative producing
or being involved in this than he was
that is 5-second secretary just hired
him in to promote this thing but why
it's so embarrassing it's like you know
a guy in it what is he fond of fat I
mean god bless or Ivana is it out of fat
I will only go see this when the mooch
and Omarosa are fillings you know when
they come out to cast all right now this
week and a former Vatican diplomat
charged that the Pope and several
bishops work to conceal and protect
sexual abusers in the Catholic Church
Chicago Archbishop Cardinal blase as sue
pitch told a local NBC affiliate that
the Pope is just too busy for all this
the Pope has a bigger agenda he's got to
get on with other things of talking
about the environment and protecting
migrants and carrying on the work of the
church we're not going to go down a
rabbit hole on this so so wait a minute
charges that there are corruption and a
culture of silence at the very upper
echelons of the church that's a rabbit
hole that affects victims today and
victims to come tell you that soup [ __ ]
comment was disgusting dismissive
and revealing of how far left the
Catholic Church has gone I can top it he
said here's the real reason that we're
seeing this resistance to Pope Francis
and these accusations watch
quite frankly they also don't like him
because he's a Latino now I don't like
him because he's Latino
bergoglio is full-blooded Italian who
grew up in Argentina so I'm more Latino
than he is but I don't know if we're
gonna have time there was a girl that
went up today we have at the papal event
the Wednesday audience in Rome and some
people thought they were yelling vegan
oh who is they gana Archbishop that made
this accusation that the Pope knew about
McCarrick misdeeds sleeping with the
seminarians deal let's let's watch the
audience
yeah yeah there there there is some
dispute as to whether this is actually
vegan oh there was a bishop on the stage
with the Pope
his name is Italia and they're saying
sounds out of kids yelling Italia Italia
some friends who I knew who were there
they claimed that it was a blend of
things it in this is like that viral
thing what was it the who is it Jonnie
Jonnie or oral yeah well on it vegan oh
you know origami oh you'll be the judge
yeah we won't cop it's a but I listened
to it sound like big enogh to me alright
what is that what does that tell on the
Pope up there don't know what does it
tell on him people are not going to tell
you he is according to reports
embittered by this but he hasn't said
anything well people are crying out you
know what guess what vegan Oh said he
said I'm completely serene and at peace
because I said the truth